my next guest you know him from space
force on netflix
mandalorian uh bojack horseman please
welcome my very funny friend
asif ali asif thank you for being here
oh oh man you know what moses
this is exactly this is exactly what i
was
what i was hoping for to meet you in
this setting i finally get to see
the inside of of where you live and and
you didn't disappoint man you didn't
disappoint you have the the saudi orb
that trump and and those guys put their
hands on
i'm i'm really pumped about it i'm also
in the book i'm also in the book
you're in the book let's see did you do
something fun for the book or you look
sad no you look so fun
just a sad guy with something so you
just did exactly your dmv
photo for that you know yeah but you
know how you were on
on the white page i was we got the i got
the brown section here
you got the brown section yeah and give
hassan the full page give him the full
page i mean he deserves it
you know yeah he is an icon and i love
that they gave him
they picked the worst for someone that
is constantly lauded on his perfect
tear it was it was a comparison
this book is a takedown to hassan full
take down
about his hair and he the one time he
didn't get
a fade up we got the sides going wild
um how are you doing because it feels
like you've stayed
busy because you do a lot of voice over
work you have an incredible voice
i've been getting into the voice game
i've been getting into the voice game
i'm doing the show called devil may care
uh for sci-fi that will be out whenever
they're done editing that
i did like a thing on uh the star trek
uh
lord dex and what if i just continued
doing that for 45 minutes
yeah it really could the amount of
things you're on you start listing
commercials you're on
ah and you sink lower and lower in the
ocean
in high school i ran the eight minute
mile
yeah absolutely definitely keep going
but um yeah i've been doing voiceover
that's been fun you're doing voiceover
work
it seems like you got a really great job
before the shutdown when you're
on the mandalorian i yeah i did the
mandalorians
that was a great gig um they
they it was so expensive
and you know you and i will we'll
usually do
we'll do like an indie thing right or
like most normal television show right
like even like sunny side it's just a tv
show and an indie show
yeah again it's a tv show kelpin had a
couple gopros
and then you go on a show and you're
like oh
if this is the whole company this isn't
just like a
oh if this doesn't do well or whatever
we'll be
fine there's always pilot season and
then there's shows where it's like
this is the fourth quarter we have
merchandise
we have a whole you know 100 million
dollar ad campaign
we have a whole thing and if if people
are not wearing big dog sized t-shirts
and these are not flying off the shelves
our whole company
will go under and so when you're working
on a thing like that
i remember i got there and walking from
the doors to where our rooms are
we had to wear a full cloak with a
hood because where we were shooting
there was a particular part of like a
highway overpass thing
and the lady was saying that people were
camping out like they were getting
dropped off like paparazzi were
driving being like i'll jump out grand
theft auto style
just to maybe get a long
distance photo of someone's random
outfit
and then some person who's so into star
wars can
sort of put together like oh that guy's
hat and his shoes
means that he might be from this planet
which might mean that the story
could be about going from here which
might be
that it blows the whole thing because
they're they're insane about it so
everyone wants a piece if you do
anything that's star wars related
people want to know things get these
there's whole websites that are just
about getting the exclusive so you had
to wear a whole cape
yeah off chance that someone would be on
a highway
and then take a a blurry photo of you
and then piece together
that you were one on this yeah and
a crucial part of the story and the
crazy part is like okay
i can tell the guy getting dropped off
and just being on a highway overpass
taking photos but then like how does he
coordinate the pickup
yeah and if you've ever dropped anything
on the highway
um it's it's a you gotta take another
80 minute lap yeah yeah it's a very it's
a very tough thing
um i'm doing i'm like in the middle of
doing a
uh a marvel show and so we shot
80 percent of that and it really is just
all credits this whole interview is just
all credits
and i'm gonna bring jay larson on he's
like i don't know i'm like a dad
uh i have like a life and so i only
bring this up to say that when people
take it
that seriously like i was talking to a
dude on there
and they're like it's like a double edge
sort of like you
don't want that kind of craziness while
you're making the show because
people are like trying to sneak into
everyone's instagram to try to like
put clues together like they're
detectives and wait this is for the
marvel show
yeah yeah yeah are you the before
picture of kamel nagioni
did you book it i went out for it it was
a very offensive audition
this is the the pre-protein shake
version yeah
minute montage
where listen would you do some reshoots
at the beginning of this
okay you're not strong enough and i'm
like i'll show you
this should be your credit just the
before picture of kamela and gianni that
people know exactly what you're
going in for can i tell you something
yeah before i finish that
i cannot stress to you how many times
and this is even with glasses awesome
and this might be subconsciously why i
wear the glasses too
how many times people will come up to me
i guess
in l.a it's like an la thing and be like
oh
you did a great job in the thing that i
definitely wasn't
in yes i brought this up not because
me me flaming racist but i was at a show
with you at westwood and they're like
from silicon valley
and they brought you up thinking you
were this was like you're once looking
back okay so please go i was just trying
to uncancel myself first
later i would later i was on silicon
valley but that
that this was year one this is yeah yeah
yeah yeah and this is what i've become
now
i just agree i
just see you don't pull the ripcord you
don't say oh no it's actually not me
because it's like yeah if you don't if
you're not going to do the work and
you're going to have
what i call white people blindness they
just like brown glasses done
done did you be like hey did you work on
that thing
that's truly all that you had to say
give yourself an
out don't be so sure even even when i
introduced your credit to the beginning
i was like bojack of course
everything's said with a rising
intonation
i just feel like there is a an agreement
though yeah amongst
all people who get confused for the
other person
where we just we are on our best
behavior we just say yes
we're on our best behavior and then we
just does this give you kind of license
to be a huge
dick like you could you could if
someone's like oh okay
yeah this is obviously cal pen then
you're just like yeah man working for
the obama administration was [ __ ]
the guy's a fake man he was totally
going to pizza restaurants all the
time and then people like he's lost it
this gives you this freedom are you ever
tempted you know what if i was really
evil that would be the move to take each
and every other indian
actor in la down be like are you you
worked in uh
you were in love birds right and i go
yeah but
also i love white supremacy when are we
bringing that back
make sure to tell your friends that i
definitely said that i met this guy
moses storm on the set of lovebirds
great way to plug myself as being in
that movie
and he opened my mind up about
white people and that you know they're
burning and they shouldn't be alive they
shouldn't be outside
and i i really think they have a point
anyway i'm going to this rally
and honestly you may not want to work
with me in the future but
there's probably a guy out there with
glasses that you should probably
definitely book
it's so cool to see you getting these
huge jobs because
i mean you and i have come up exactly at
the same time i feel like where
we've been on sets that are just exactly
like you're saying these indie things
where it's like a friend's
favor the budget is like a tangerine
and some goldfish we did a web series
for subway together
oh my god that's a real thing
that no one can find the record out
because they have pulled it
because jared from subway made a little
appearance and this is before
uh people understood branded content so
with a certain
large streaming network that i won't
name uh
whereas dip in their toes and it was a
subway
sponsored very heavy-handed product
placement slash
show sitcom that we all worked at a
subway
and you were brought in i didn't know
jared made an appearance
yeah well i was in it with him this is
the thing i've been trying to track down
so
please if anyone out there can find this
i can't tell you the amount of money i
would pay if there's got to be
some record of it because there's
there's nothing you kept
you kept it on your reel not the jared
part but yeah
there is there is like a he comes in
there's like a funny interaction
yeah you can talk to him about his life
i was like so what's your life like like
what do you do he goes oh that's pretty
chill let's do these corporate events
and then nothing else but there's actual
video of me doing a behind-the-scenes
thing and i'm like you know
21 trying to get like just lucky to be
there
and i say about jared's like it's so
cool to see jared
because every subway you go and you see
the cardboard cutout of him you know
and now he's on the set he's essentially
like the brad
pitt of subway there's that pull quote
from me
oh my god can you imagine people don't
realize how many things like that
you have to do to get one thing that
you're okay with talking about in public
have you done
commercials in the lockdown because it's
a little bit different process
now can i tell you something really so
whenever so they're doing commercials in
home yes you're 100 right
have i done any of them no and part of
the reason is because they're always
like
you know yes they want to shoot
commercials and they want to shoot in
your house but if your house
doesn't look like a set
they don't want to be involved with you
so i have a lot of people who are like
oh yeah we worked with austin before
he's great let's definitely bring him on
this is a commercial with dj khaled
whoever right
yeah and your house has to match dj
khaled's house
an impossible task an impossible task
you don't have a jet ski i have a jet
ski i don't have
marble and they're like yeah so dj
khaled comes up and he goes hey cool
and you're supposed to be brushing your
teeth and i'm like
is he in my house or is he is it
supposed to be like
is it supposed to look like his house
and they're like i don't know sort of
like in between
and then you do the audition and they're
like great that's super fun now can you
give us a tour
of your house and then you take your
camera and you're like okay
and you're like showing them your house
and then you can kind of
sense the deflated like your house is
bombing essentially
it's like you booked it but the house
didn't book it your sad apartment
they're like oh the wealth inequality
gap is too large between you
and dj khaled i'm like i'm like i like
my place but i can just feel it i'm just
like
ah well i guess we're just gonna have to
find somebody else because this guy is
living in a tent it seems this will not
work
seems to be living under a freeway
trying to capture photos of star wars
your apartment does look like edward
norton's place before he blows it up in
fight club
the same rug where it's like i just sort
of i'm a corporate machine i have a
zigzag rug
everything from the ikea catalog i eat
noodles there every night and i
just want to change my life i just want
to punch myself in the face
it is a great out for us though if you
don't book something it's like they
didn't like the place
you know dude i'm going to keep using it
even when we can
audition in person again they could they
could smell me they could sense the
zigzag carpet
they had it out for me they knew i had
laid on that carpet
panicking about this audition this was
so great talking to you i just missed
talking to you and seeing you around
likewise dude maybe i'll just show up
outside your window one of these days
please do and i'm like what ha
hassaminaj
uh it is it's great to see you so it's
mandalorian
people obviously know about that marvel
project is coming out
a bunch of voice over work uh yeah devil
may care we'll be on nbc sci-fi
sometime uh in the new year
very excited about it and then subway is
doing some fantastic
branded content that you have to check
out please find this for us
because we need to do a whole show about
the behind the scenes of this awesome
valley everyone
good see anybody bye bye
he's in the book